tout simplement moi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] je suis très je m'en foutisme
c'est ma paix
je
ne cherche pas oui je cherche pas le
buzz en fait genre
le public a accroché avec moi j'y peux
rien après bien entendu voilà je fais du
business je crée des entreprises etc
voilà maintenant
je gagne bien ma vie combien tu peux me
donner deux noms d'entre eux j'ai l'eau
de mon bain d'entreprises la première et
la deuxième ce que tu as dit je crée des
entreprises l'image que ce serait bien
que tu dises aux gens j'ai créé plein
d'entreprises et qui nous donne là le
nom de tes entreprises ça sera un bon
message pour les jeunes qui nous
regardent le nom de trois entreprises
non trois entreprises des entreprises
débiles qui laisse et pourquoi pas donc
pourquoi pas alors je l'assie
500000 débiles qui la suivent prends
l'exemple d'un mandatar tu me prends
l'exemple
toi tu vas te faire mal non mais il y a
des abonnés
c'est pas la même époque il y avait pas
les dégâts internet il y avait pas les
jeux
comme un Dieu qui avait pas la
téléréalité tu arrêtes avec cette
chaussure
dans une église parce que ça part en
vrai
non mais qu'est-ce que tu racontes on
parle de ce qu'il bug si si si la la si
le la ligne du temps de l'émission tu
peux y aller hein
[Applaudissements]
il faut y aller
c'est mon ami il dormira à la maison
si ça se trouve sur gamin la
suites
c'est sûr
est-ce qu'on peut discuter
en même temps tu te fous de ma gueule
merci